who are the top musicians in the world
in your opinion you're a guy who loves
rock and roll you play the guitar even
on stage you will you know dabble in a
couple of songs as a musician who is it
you admire all right uh love Neil Young
absolutely love Neil Young because he's
managed to stay completely authentic and
raw in a way that it almost seems
impossible to me do you know what I mean
he's whatever what he was doing and with
Buffalo Springfield in 1965 he's still
going for that he hasn't calcified he
has encrusted over he's still going for
that and so that guy blows me away and
you mentioned Neil Young And when we go
back in Conan O'Brien history Neil Young
was a really incredible force in your
life when you were going through all
your horrible [ __ ] with The Tonight Show
Jay Leno we all know the story Neil
Young
was your was he your last guest yeah I
don't know if he's because it's all a
blur to me now and I have PTSD and I'm
medicated uh but
it's like a good move right but yeah
Neil Young came on and uh I think it did
uh long may you run and I just you know
this is such a beautiful thing it was
just it was amazing but he he was one of
those guys who really identified with
what you were going through and
supported you and didn't think what was
being done by the corporate NBC uh
bigwig's way to you know he he was vocal
no no he was to use my people's term a
mensch he was a mensch about the whole
thing he was great he was a really
lovely guy did you form a relationship
with him outside of uh not really no and
I gotta say I don't know I get
intimidated by that I if I was going to
meet Neil Young for a cup of coffee I
would be I would get in my head about it
because it's Neil Young and I do feel
that way I mean another guy on my list
who you've interviewed I think you've
done my the best interviews with him of
anybody is Paul McCartney because I'm
such a Beatles fanatic and I've found
that the couple times I've interviewed
him or been around him it gets weird I'm
just looking at his hands and thinking
those are the hands that made the chords
that did this and that and I think
there's no you can't go down that road
he's a guy and you you got to just let
all that go that is so interesting that
you're saying this because when I was
interviewing Bruce Springsteen right he
was sitting at the piano and I was
watching his hands play the piano when
he was playing Thunder Road and this guy
is just playing this music that
resonates with me but his hands were
fascinating because I don't know what I
was expecting in a weird way it's no
it's true when Einstein died they did an
autopsy and they removed his brain and
they were just expecting it's gonna have
instead of two lobes it's gonna have
three it's gonna be glowing blue it's it
was quite average they could see nothing
unusual about it and it's the brain that
conceived of all the best ideas of the
20th century and no nothing and I think
that's true I look at these people
sometimes if you I heard this once if
you if you put someone on a pedestal all
you're doing is degrading yourself but
I've done it so many times with my
comedy Heroes with my music Heroes and
you think yeah Bruce is a guy who he's
amazing he's one of the great forces in
entertainment history and but he's a guy
who yeah you know those are his hands
those are the same hands as he uses to
open up a bag of Doritos and they're no
different than our hands
foreign